if you are looking to downsize or add
another addition to your house all while
cutting costs a tiny home on wheels
may be the answer for you 8 news now
reporter victoria saha gives a look at
tiny homes on display at the home
improvement and backyard expo
you may think this is your average size
home it's got everything you need but
it's a little smaller say hello to
another concept of living
with tiny homes your average home or
apartment has a living room bedroom
and a bathroom which seems to be basic
necessities for a home
but what about if you can get just that
without the extra space
and half the cost it's just like a
apartment except
a lot cheaper i have you know a full
bathroom a full kitchen
i got my bedroom so i absolutely love it
jenna hall is 21 years old
and already owns her first tiny home
builders say it's the younger buyers
like
hall that are mostly taking part in this
unique way of living we are now
bringing back the starter home the one
bedroom
home or the studio home that can be
lived in and
bought at a very affordable price tiny
homes started 60 thousand dollars
depending on size
bayer also says it would be great for
people looking to add an addition to
their house
without having to wait to build it if we
had to downsize
that would be where we go tiny homes
they're just so great and they have
wheels making it easier to pick up and
leave this day when everyone is so full
of excess
if you didn't need the extra space maybe
you wanted to travel and have a second
home it would be ideal
the tiny homes expo runs until sunday
june 13th
reporting from the world market center
victoria zaha 8 news now